III do I struggle with stuff every day
still hmm like I struggle with addiction
man like it is I'm an addictive person
like it would be very easy for me to
drink a half a bottle to a bottle of
Jameson every single day probably not a
whole bottle but but you know what if I
if I started with a half a bottle I
probably get to a bottle eventually yeah
you work your way up to it yeah man um
narcotics god dude narcotics sure do
make you feel good I mean it's like a
really nice easy quick fix but man like
the the when I say struggle with those
things every day um it might in my
because I had struggle with that stuff
so much in my past it might be something
where you know I'm thinking about
relationship with my dad or something
and it's like man you know what if I
could just take a pill right now that
would really just kind of like mask all
that pain or on the on the other end of
the spectrum drinking is something that
I'd love to celebrate with a drink well
celebrating with ten drinks is
definitely not healthy but I but if I if
I did not have limitations if I didn't
have good habits then these these things
could certainly end up being a problem
because I think you're talking about the
residue of the past too and that yeah
that always carries forward so what
you're talking about is you talk about
some past habits that have changed right
and so so you well what I understand is
like - in order for for me to keep my
life clear of clutter
it also means keeping my mind clear of
clutter and those things especially
narcotics do not add to the clarity it
makes it more cluttered if anything
right I mean dr. green last night when
we were when we were all having dinner
he showed us a picture of the dude who I
forget his name from Mighty Ducks but
he's like the goalie and mighty does and
he was like this you know chubby fat
like cute kid who was a goalie in this
movie in this kid's movie and he just
got arrested not too long ago for a DUI
and he looks like my grandfather he
looks like the result of a long lived
hard life yeah and and it's not even
that it's long because it's painful
right and and what you're talking about
there's no judgment here
it's just a matter of your identifying
yeah absolutely absolutely the other
thing I struggle with too man is dude I
always want to buy new stuff I wish I
could sit here and say hey listen to our
podcasts read our books and you will
never want to buy anything again ever
you will be you will be free of this
urge to buy stuff that's just not the
case man yeah I mean it's like any one's
telling you that they're there they're
probably misleading yeah yeah absolutely
man I mean I think about I know I talk
about Mariah and eyes Tata Corolla a lot
but you know I'm saving money for a new
car and I really want to buy a new Tesla
like if I stayed up for another two
years three years I could probably have
$60,000 to drop on a Tesla right but the
problem though is that I don't have it
$60,000 is a lot of money for me a lot
of money for a lot of people but but my
point is is that I'm not a well going
with Dave Ramsey's suggestion yeah he
says you know if you're if you're a
millionaire okay you can afford to buy a
new car you know if your net worth is
more than a million dollars you can
afford the person to call right by the
way the average so that Chris Hogan has
that new book coming out in January
called every day millionaire's yeah and
they did a the most comprehensive study
of millionaires throughout the the
country and more than 10,000
millionaires and by the way when we say
millionaires we're talking a lot of
teachers and nurses we're not talking
about finance guys and and and bankers
and everyday people everyday people and
large percentage of them have made less
than $60,000 a year they yeah our life
absolutely they've just made good
decisions with the resources they have
absolutely but keep going with the Dave
Ramsey things well when he talks about
with millionaires is you have a million
dollar net worth then you're you're able
to buy a new car but your average
millionaire drives a car that is three
years old or older right because
millionaires didn't become millionaires
but buying a new car every year yeah you
don't become a millionaire by spending
your money but but you know to to at
least this questionnaire she asks you
know how you know what kind of tools do
we use to help us through these these
problems we
in like Dave Ramsey he's one of those
guys like I the book said he that he has
a radio show whatever it may be like
that's a tool that I used to help keep
myself in check so yeah like if I was if
I had a net worth of a million bucks
still would be very hard for me to drop
that type of money on a car but at least
at least I could like here's what I
envision if you know if you and I ever
you know become millionaires um if I
drop sixty thousand dollars on a car I
would have to drop sixty thousand
dollars on building schools in Laos but
right now I'm not in a position to where
I can I can take a hundred twenty
thousand dollars and divide it up like
that right so so because of these
principles because of these tools that I
use like no I'm not gonna go out and buy
a Tesla like I've been talking about buy
a Tesla for a couple years I ain't gonna
do it now I mean unless unless I have an
expendable income if someone drops ten
million dollars on your lap yeah here's
the thing you you and I are kit for
example we're helping build the grocery
store you and I are donating over
$20,000 over own money and I would
rather do that then have a Tesla yeah
yeah yeah and and yet you could like
hoard that money and say well I'm going
to and it'd be okay it's your money you
do whatever the hell you want with your
money yeah and I'm not sure like this is
not me virtue signaling and I'm not
trying to make anyone feel bad out there
for owning at us well I just want to be
very clear on that I'm just answering
Elise's question on the problems that I
have mm-hm and and how I'm able to
overcome those problems that I have but
it is through reasoning like this it's
through different tools that help me to
keep good habits because emotionally
it's really easy to say in the moment
man that'd be great I could figure out a
way to afford the monthly payment on a
Tesla or whatever right yeah and well I
could afford the payment right you just
can't afford the car right there are two
more cartoons I want to share with you
Ryan of cartoons so so this is another
New Yorker one Jordan I'll give this to
you afterward you want to describe what
this says but before you before it says
what it says just describe the room all
right there's a woman walking through it
looks like an apartment door she has a
scolding look on her face and there's a
dude sitting in the middle of an empty
room hardwood floor sitting on the chair
with a smirk so she's yelling he's
smirking in an empty room
he came Hurley wait
hmm the caption says you came home early
just so you could get the chair
well that's great so I think people
often think of minimalism like this
right like I use it yeah I do but that
yeah this is deprivation oh man exactly
and so that's the thing that I want to
communicate here with Elise is yeah
you'll struggle with certain things but
this isn't the answer having the house
with nothing in it is not what we're
going for I mean you were at my house
last night yeah there were six of us
there we had a table with six of us
eating dinner on plate yeah we all had
our own seat almost
I wasn't that why you were sitting on my
lap yeah yeah but I still had to see it
I could use it but Jordan if you want to
put that on on-camera somehow so with
Elise keep that in mind as you're
letting go yes the the cluttering of the
stuff is not the end result because that
would be your end result in fact you
have to get rid of the chair that's too
much stuff right why do you have a chair
you're not a real minimalist without a
chair that's funny man I just said
that's not popping in my head like we
always talk about how someone could rent
a dumpster or throw away all their stuff
and still be miserable in an empty
apartment like the the the minimal is
the the exciting part of minimalism it
is the journey like it is fit is taking
this tool and it's helping one to figure
out exactly what adds value to their
life and like that process the process
of doing that like that is that's the
fun part
yeah having it having an empty room
adjust the chair in it like that's not
much fun we're meaningful for that
matter right for most people but if you
want to live that way I think of our
friend Colin right now who's out getting
ready got on tour right now the becoming
tour I think is becoming tour calm he's
doing 26 cities in this next year but
for the last two years he's lived in an
apartment they because he's focused on
creating his podcast and he was renting
an apartment in Memphis for the last
year and he got you know the basics he
had a desk and a chair
I'm sure his house his apartment looked
fairly similar to that with a few other
accoutrements right and and in doing
that that's what was appropriate for him
he doesn't like having company over and
lay so he had what worked just for him
in his own space and that's fine now
that he's he's getting ready to leave he
had to even get rid of some of the stuff
so I'm guarantee his apartment looks
really similar to that right now I'm
gonna this is a third and final cartoon
but this reminds me this cartoon
reminded me of Elise when I was thinking
about her question I saw this cartoon
and I was like this is where Elise is
right now of course you know Alice in
Wonderland
right yes this the title of this one at
the top says Alice and responsibilities
land and she's coming home so there's
her she's walked into her kitchen yeah
and everything that is there it's like
the door says locked me and the umbrella
says put me away and the food on the
counter says cook me and the dishes in
the sink say wash me and the freezer
says defrost me and the fridge says fill
me and the window says look through me
and the email and the computer says
check me and the plates on the table say
clear us and the bottle of alcohol in
the table says don't drink me and the
cupcake on the table says don't eat me
and the bills on the table say pay us
and the the purse in her hand says put
me down and the chairs on her are at her
kitchen table say wipe us down and the
floor says sweep me that is a genius
cartoon man and they're so good and we
get overwhelmed with these
responsibilities and for me minimalism
is a way not to remove this
responsibilities I'll give this to you
Jordan seeing put that in know it's a
way to choose yes it's the way it's a
way to pick better responsibilities what
am I going to be responsible about
because I'll have to be responsible to
something in someone why not choose
those deliberately instead of just
having to deal with the next
responsibility that fills our life yeah
absolutely well at least I'd love to
send you a copy of our book minimalism
live a meaningful life Shawn if you
could reach out to her and send her the
audiobook version if you like the the
podcast then you'll probably like the
audiobook version of this it's a
relatively short book it's like two and
a half hours long it's our shortest book
and it goes over the five values the one
thing that we didn't talk to you about
is identifying getting really focused on
what your values are because at least
you said you want to be focused and
value
value-driven and if you want to be
value-driven well then you better be
driven by the right values because it's
possible to not have the right values
that are gonna move you forward and then
you're gonna be like that deflating
balloon that we talked about so we'll
give you the audiobook version of that
or if you want the book book version of
the eBook version we'll be happy to give
you a copy of live a meaningful life in
any of those formats
you